Ich weiß nicht.
Guten Tag. Ich begrüße Sie. Ich bin aus der Stadt Trump.
Ich will Ihnen genau das Gespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Gerne, bitte schön.
Ja, bevor wir beginnen, habe ich eine eigene Frage an Sie.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Klaus Müller.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vorunachnahme Maxan Buchstabieren?
Klaus, H-L-A-U-S, Müller, M-U-L-L-E-R.
Alles klar. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Müller?
Ich bin 70 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie gerne geworden?
Am 2. Januar 1955.
1955? Ja.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1.000 Jahre alt.
Alles klar.
Und Herr Müller, was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit 3 Tagen Fieber, Schüttelfrost und Husten sehr stark.
Haben Sie Fieber und Strafrost?
Ich Husten sehr stark.
Husten Sie, ja.
Haben Sie Ausruf oder bemerkt?
Ich habe gelbgrünen Ausruf, habe ich bemerkt.
Haben Sie die Fieber gemessen?
Ich habe gemessen zu Hause, war 39,2.
Gestern oder wann sind Sie genau gemessen?
Heute habe ich gemessen 39,2. Gestern war es bei 38,8.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden in Ihrer Familie?
Nein, meine Frau ist gesund.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder MGF-Atemnot?
Ja, wenn ich Huste, habe ich sehr stark Brustschmerzen.
Und beim Einatmen auch.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
lange, lange vorher glaube ich, aber das war nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Es geht jetzt über 3 Tage lang.
Alles klar.
Sind Sie vorstellig geimpft?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Gegen Corona auch?
Ich war vor kurzem noch bei meinem Hausarzt.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Nein.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang und der Masse?
Nein.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Aber ich schwitze generell auch Tagsüber.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich bin ein bisschen apetitlos.
Ich fühle mich auch sehr schwach.
Seit wann fühlen Sie sich schwach?
3 Tage.
Haben Sie unwirklich ab und zu genommen in der letzten Zeit?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Dann werden wieder Ihre Beschwerden kommen.
Haben Sie vorherkrankungen?
Ich habe einige vorherkrankungen.
Ich habe einen Diabetes.
Ich habe Blutdruck.
Ich habe Hördekolestering.
Seit wann haben Sie Diabetes?
Seit über 10 Jahren.
Ich habe Blutdruck seit 8 Jahren.
Seit 8 Jahren?
Ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Diabetes?
Seit 10 Jahren.
Ich habe Blutdruck.
Ich habe Hördekolestering.
Seit wann haben Sie Diabetes?
Seit 10 Jahren.
Ich nehme für den Diabetes Med1.
Im Abend nehme ich einer tableIde does 1.
für welche Zucker oder für Bulltochdruck?
Ich habe 16 Milligramm morgens und abends und für die Kolesterol nehme ich einmal abends
und ich habe 40 Milligramm morgens.
Wo denn du schon mal operiert?
Ich wurde schon mal operiert, ja. Ich habe die Galle rausbekommen.
Wann haben diese Operation gehabt?
Das war vor 15 Jahren.
Sonst haben sie andere Operation gehabt, oder?
Sonst bin ich schon mal operiert.
Alles klar.
Und haben sie Allergien?
Ich habe keine Allergien.
Und verzerrt nicht, was haben sie, oder?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Alles klar.
Und gibt es chronische Erklaren in jeder Familie?
Also meine Eltern sind gestorben, ja?
Ja.
Ich bin schon alt, meine Kinder sind gesund.
Und Woran gestorben, ich stürze mich leid, Woran gestorben,
alle Eltern wissen Sie?
Also meine Mutter ist ein Herz, sie ist plötzlich gestorben,
man sagte, es wäre ein Herzinfarkt gewesen,
mein Vater ist gestorben, einer Demenz.
Meine Vater war noch jung, der ist mit 65 Jahren gestorben.
Und Mutter ist gestorben.
Mutter ist auch gestorben, Mutter ist am Herz,
wahrscheinlich Herzinfarkt.
Und wie alt ist sie?
Wie alt war sie?
Wie alt sie waren damals?
Die war auch, glaube ich, ungefähr so 22 Jahre alt.
Und wie alt war sie?
Die war auch, glaube ich, ungefähr so 72 Jahre alt oder 73,
wie meine ich ganz sicher.
Alles klar.
Und Sie sind einzelne Kinder, und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Was ist Sie vom Beruf?
Rentner.
Rentner, und was haben Sie früher?
Ich war Architekt.
Rentner, und leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau oder Ihre Familie?
Leben Sie mit meiner Frau zusammen, ja.
Und ich würde fragen, rauchen Sie her?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Haben Sie früher geraucht, oder?
Auch nicht, nein.
Das ist super.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr selten.
Also ganz selten, nur bei Feiern.
Wie kann man das formulieren?
Du Beispiel einmal in einem Monat, oder?
Ne, weniger, noch weniger, alle paar Monate.
Alles klar.
Wenn Geburtstag ist, wenn eine Feier ist, in Feiertage sind dann?
Ja, Sie rauchen nicht und trinken Sie weniger Alkohol.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Drogen konsumieren.
Aber ich muss das...
Aber ich bin nicht so alt.
Alles klar.
Wir kommen zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden wieder.
Und haben Sie sonst Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Übelkeit,
oder Erbrochen, oder nur Husten und Fieber haben Sie?
Genau.
Alles klar.
Und jetzt haben Sie eine Geschwerung in der Haar bemerkt, oder?
Nein, haben Sie nicht.
Okay, Herr Müller, wir haben mit unserem Gespräch fertig.
Und sind Ihnen etwas Wichtiges eingefallen?
Und haben Sie einen Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich würde gern wissen, was Sie jetzt machen,
ob das etwas Schlimmes sein könnte, oder...
Was glauben Sie, was habe ich?
Ist das nur eine krippale Infekt, oder was habe ich?
Als Anonymitischer Agnabendreuten Sie eine Lungenentsündung...
Oh, eine Lungenentsündung.
Aber können wir das genau nach dem Alluntersuchungen sein?
Nach diesem Gespräch werden wir körperlich Untersuchungen dann abnehmen.
Und dann werden wir noch andere weiter diagnostisch Angaben durchführen.
Was werden Sie noch machen?
Ich will ein Torax-Röntgen machen.
Torax?
Brust-Röntgen.
Ja.
Hab ich etwas mit der Brust oder habe ich etwas mit der Lunge?
Diese Untersuchung zeigt uns, was Sie in der Brustbereich haben.
Dunken oder Brunchen.
Das kann man dann sehen da, ja?
Ja, damit wir mehr wissen, was Sie genau haben.
Dann mit allen Ergebnissen, wenn dann mit allen Ergebnissen besprechen,
etwas mit Ihnen wieder.
Dann, ja.
Okay, das kann.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Das war sehr schön.
Haben Sie sich füblich?
Ja.
Haben Sie gemessen?
Hab ich mir die Frage beantwortet.
Hatten Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Erkältung oder eine Reparation?
Ich hatte vor vier Wochen schon mal einen Infekt gehabt.
Okay.
Waren Sie damals beim Hausarzt, oder?
Ja, ich war beim Hausarzt.
Ich hatte einen Krippaleinfekt.
Er hat mir dann Ibuprofen aufgeschrieben und dann war es auch mal ein paar Tage besser geworden.
Nur Ibuprofen, okay.
Genau, nur Ibuprofen, richtig.
Haben Sie Schmerzen bei meinem Einatzen oder aussatmen?
Hab ich auch beantwortet, ja.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Großschmerzen habe ich.
Und sind Sie eher stechend, dumpf, rennend?
Stechende Schmerzen sind das.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Hüste beschreiben?
Das ist eine Attacke oder immer ständig?
Oder wann sind Sie schlimmer geworden?
Nein, das ist nicht Attacke für mich.
Das kommt ab und zu.
Dann rust ich ein paar Mal und dann ist der Schleim raus.
Bitte, auch könnten Sie beschreiben Ihre Fieber tagsüber
oder insbesondere bestimmte Tagzeit?
Also das habe ich nicht gemessen.
Ich habe morgens und abends gemessen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt hat, Herr Tocan.
Könnten wir als als...
Ich war auch nicht im Ausland gewesen.
Okay, gut.
Könnten wir als als geschebte Anfang, Herr Tocan?
Ja.
Ja, haben Sie?
Alles klar.
Bitte schön.
Herr Obererz, grüß mein Name.
Ich habe neue Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen. Darf ich?
Gerne.
Okay.
Es geht um Klaus Müller.
Er ist 70 Jahre alt und ist am 1., 2., 950 geboren.
Er ist 173...
1 Meter 73 groß und wiegt 81 kg.
Er stetzt sich in unserer Ambulanz seit 3 Tagen bestehende Fieber und Hüsten.
Boah.
Und als begleitende Plumme hatte er gelbliche grüne Ausrüffung
und die Fieber sei 39,2 C gemessen.
Und begleit September Wutherferneid, er habe keine Übelkeit,
und er brach.
Und er hatte als vegetative Anamnensaktiv Nachzweiß-Appetitlosigkeit
fatig seit 3 Tagen.
und an Vorerkrankungen habe er die Apthes Melitus, Hypertonie und Hyperchlorostämie
und er nehme dagegen Metformin, Candesatan und Atavocetin ein
und bei ihm wurde vor 15 Jahren Cholestomie durchgeführt und er habe keine Allergien
und er ist ein sehr Kind und sein Vater sei an Demenz verstorben
bei seinem Mutter ist er an Hessinfarkt verstorben
er sei verheiratet, er habe drei jesunde Kinder und er saure nicht und trinke sehr sehr viel Alkohol
und als Analyseangaben durften auf akute Pynomonie hin aber kommen akute Ptonsylaktomie und Mediastinitis auf per Dachs im Betracht
Wie kam man, ist das Fieber plötzlich auch getreten oder war das nach und nach, haben Sie das gefragt?
Ist er plötzlich krank geworden oder hat er, das ist es zudem jetzt?
Es hat mir jetzt angefangen, entfallen aber er hat seit drei Tagen Fieber
Er hat das Fieber plötzlich angefangen oder hat er sich davor schon krank gefühlt, wissen Sie das?
Leider habe ich nicht gefragt, sollte ich fragen
Sie glauben mehr hat eine Lumenentzündung wahrscheinlich?
Ja, weil grünliche Auswurf und Fieber und Hüsten
Kann das auch noch normale Bronschitis sein?
Das könnte auch eine Bronschitis sein
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten jetzt?
Jetzt erstmal für fallische Untersuchung dann Blut abnehmen
Ich meine Entzündungswerte, er ist alte Patient, Nierenwerte, Lerbewerte
Er hat erwähnt, dass er ein bisschen Brötchenmessen habe
Das wäre besser, wenn wir auch Herzliche Enzyme überprüfen
Dann Röntgen-Torax machen damit wir sehen ob er eine Infiltration in Lunge hat
Können Sie eine Influencer ausschließen?
Ja, wir können auch eine Abstriche nehmen
Was sollten Sie noch machen bei dem Verdacht einer Lungenentzündung in der Ambulanz?
Was sollten Sie noch für eine Untersuchung machen?
Ganz wichtig
Köperschuntersuchung ist sehr wichtig
Röntgen, EKG, Luftnot
Was sollten Sie kontrollieren?
Noch etwas
Wenn jemand Luftnot hat, er kommt mit Luftnot
Das ist Sauerstoffsetigung
Das gehört zum EKG
Eine Sache noch ganz wichtig, was sollten Sie kontrollieren?
Blutdruck oder Köperschuntersuchung, Vitalparameter und EKG
Röntgen
Wissen Sie, was eine BGA ist?
Ja, kenne ich, Blutdruck als Analyse
Wenn Sie mit kontrollieren, können Sie auch bei den Patienten nicht richtig beobachten
Das wäre ganz wichtig
Ja, das ist ein wichtiger Analyse
Wenn Sie eine Blutgasanalyse machen, kann man das kontrollieren
Dann kann man sehen, wie der HB ist, wie die Sättigung ist
Dosis, Respirator, Metabolisch
Und die VDI-Eliut, das können Sie alles ganz gut sehen
Er ist ja kein junger Patient, er ist schon etwas älter, da sollte man vorsichtig sein
Nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf oder ausmachen Sie mit dem?
Wenn sich der Verdacht bestätigt, dass er eine Lungenentzündung hat
Da gibt es einen Skala, damit wir helfen, ob der Patient stationär behandeln muss
Der Patient ist 75 Jahre alt, er bekommt einen Punkt
Aber der Konfusion ist nicht gesund und orientiert, dann ist er nur Respirator
Das ist auch wichtig und mit dem Hochdruck, wenn der Patient nilsiger Druck hat
Da kommt auch noch einen Punkt, aber ich würde gerne stationär aufnehmen
Ja, würde ich auch machen, was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Wenn Sie die Station aufnehmen, dann einen Zugang legen, dann Flüssigkeit zuvor
Und Elektrolyt, nach dem Ergänz, wissen wir ja mehr
Aber nach dem Ergänz, die Schienele Antibiotik, IV geben, dann noch Pales
Was würden Sie geben, was für eine Antibiotik?
Ich würde erst mal am Oxygen Club nicht geben
Kann er auch, ja, das ist gut an
Was machen Sie noch auf der Station?
Was können Sie noch supportive Therapie machen?
Ja, wir machen Atemrabiltation
Atemübungen, Direktion
Atemübungen, für uns Therapie
Was geben Sie noch ein bisschen in der Lativa, um das Ganze zu lösen?
Und wie so ein Anängesik und Antipyritik geben
Hab ich nicht verstanden
Antipyritik gegen Fieber
Antipyritika
Was geben Sie da?
Das könnte Metamizol sein, Parastemol
Wenn er keine Allergien hat, dann können wir alles geben
Sehr gut, gut
Ich bedanke mich
Ich bedanke mich auch